come forward I got it around around back
around
you
watch the clock when that arms not there
there's a back a little boy I use his
arm to guide me to his face I don't want
to knock his hand out of the way and
then have to aim for that tracks right
inside of his arm
you
Hey
but I'm gonna take him to 12 that one
then I bring him up
and now I'm going to throw in this case
can be wonderful hey we're gonna do that
about five times in a row okay bye watch
way backs wait did you guys leave it
here it's in position
see whether candidates he throws the
punch at my face so when I turn this
like you don't know also it's not that I
have it if the honey was out there
shooting is carried it straight the
reason that you're preparing it with the
elbows because it was on the central I
understand just right should be
fortified
you
standing here and I didn't like the
stance I was fighting even left it left
my left foot forward I changed my stance
to see how they're doing on my foot
changes and I come back that's kind of
it that is exactly what you guys do on
this technique will be meaning come on
and now you're here and then you guys
will like this you have a really
Internet all very much
you're like here you haven't yet gotten
here you're over here and you're trying
to do the ATV 10 huh
take the step here your second hand
can't be out you idiot male second man
is here it's more like he runs into your
strife you understand
I hear block okay it's not like my
brother and I right it's not like it's
here we kind of back but I keep going
around the detention point
and you do this step here right and now
you're gonna take her balance boom you
see she's gonna hit my leg the leg has
to go out of the leg and then I have to
blend with her come on I want to be your
partner
I don't want to see this I'm gonna fight
this has to be addressed
what's with us